THANKS FOINING USONIG.
T'SET RHT T MY OPE
NIGHS OPEN IS A CHRISTMAS
CAL TOANCYELOS
CHRTMAS CAROL OF COURSE WAS
WRITTEN B CHAES DICKENS
VITEDY GSTS OF OF HIS PT
AND CONONTEY MISKES
HAS MADE IN T PAS
UNOW WHO WON
>>UMBU
JUDGE ANIN THEUEION HR
HER.TION IS EN AVAABO
E FIRST GHO T VIT NCY
AMECA.HO LAWLESS
NANCYS T LEAEMOCRAT I
NGRE, YOU COULD HAVTOPP
TH.
T Y RUSEDO D S
IN FAC Y S YOUON'TUNRSTA WHEREHS
LAESSLESS COMESROM.
>>T'S ABSUTELUTRAGEOUS.
OBOUSLYT C'TONNUE.
WLESSNESS IN OUR COURY TTSPRINGE
YBEOU DO.
CANNOT HEHAT LAWLESSNESS
BECO THE NOR
NANCY.E: NAN, NCY
YOU DON'TNOW WREHE
LAESSNS COMROM?
WOURITY O
BREATHKING BEAUTIF WREPEOPLE'TVL
EIR DOGS BECSEF H
FECES ONHETREEEEDL
NING THETRTS.
AN PEOE DON WTO GET
CAUGHT UP IN T CRIN ERY
G CITY R BY DEMOCRA.
LAWLESSNS NS BECAU YOU
MOCRATSEE T POLLS.
WITHHEOSSF LAW A OERED UP
AND THE RPANT COS ON THE
THE UNPVOKESSAUS,
COICTEDELONS LETUT OF JL
LONG BEFOR THEELEA DAT
BY DEMRA PROSECURS A
GORNOR
COD ITEHEN THE ORGANIZEDRGANED
LIKEOUIEUITT.ITOT TOOLOSE T HE?A
VOINGOOR O CRIMINALS WK
NEVE T RETN.PICE STION
IMALSRELLOW T STE
SS THAN $1,0 REPTEDL A
T EVEN BE AESTED.
SOHEY REPTEDL AND SERLLY
HITTOREND THEN SELL THE
STOLEN GOO O T STREE OF
SAN FRANCISC WHI YOUOOK THEOTR .
THAWLESSNESS THATSATE
STRONG M COUNTRY.
E OTHER GST T VIT YOU IS
IMMIATN.
WHILE W SUFR HRDES OF
ILLELLIN CINGNTOUR
COTRY.OU CHILDREN AYING FRO
FENTANYL ST BYHINAHROUTH MEXICAL
ADDEO CNTFEIT PLS LIKEXANAX TT N
ERICS.
EYAIMNDIM INNENT
ERICANS.WHAT IS YOUR ANSRBOUTS-3
MEMBS?
D WN Y WERSKED AUT
THEHUGS WHO MAIND KILL AS
RTF THEIRNITIION, Y
SAY EY A A CHIRENF
GOD.
>> WEELIEVE, SE O USHO
ARETTRACTED TTHE PLIC
ARA AND TO GOVNMENND
BLICERVI THAT W ALL
D'SHILDREN.
THERES APA OF DIFCULT - A SPA OF
DIVITY IN EVE PERN O
EART AND WE HE TO RESPECT
JUDGE JEANINE:NDANCY, THE
OS OF GRE COM TISIT
YOU.
AT'S A B ONE FND YOU
YOU MADYO KNE MILONS.YO WENT IOO
DERA MEANS AND COVER EH
REWARDSMERINSAN'T REAP
49 MEMBERSF CONGRESS AND 82
SENIORTAFFS VLATEDHE
OCK ACTHE INSERRADI
>> SHOULEMRS OF CGRS BE
ND FROM TRADING INDIDUAL
STOC WHI IN OICE?
>>NTO, TSS A FREART
ANDEHOUL BE AE TOECONOMY
PAICIPE IN THA
JUE JNINE: THISROUG
DEMOCRAT N IN CGRESS.
PSD ON THI IUE. IAVEEARD
JUDGJEANE: TOUT TS I
CONTT, SCEECOMG SPEAKER
THE HSEN 28.NANCY'SOTALSSETENTN
"60 MINUT"CCUS YOU2
SBAND PL O IIDRADI.ANDANCY, THRN
PUIC IS ANOTHERHOST THAT
WI HNT YOU
ASPEAK O THEOUSE YOUET
E TEND POLICY FOR ALL OF
US.YO LIE ARE T MANY TO
IDTIFY.
THIS O.WEEY FORIT ONE I
MR.RESIDENT, ISONOR
ANDLEASE TBE HE A TS
COROVIS.E A T
OUROUNT COU NOT BORE
ULD TE BTERERVE THA
WI T MOS EERIENCED,
PRIDENT BIDEN.
HE JUST PERCT.
THE TING CLDTE BT.
ANADAM VE PSIDE WE ARE
INSPIREDY YR WK FHE
PEOPLE AS YOU CTINUO B A
VALULEARER TO PSIDE
BIDEN.
>> T PRESIDENT A PERFE
PRESENT, THEICE PRESIDENT A
PERFT VIRESINT.
NANCY, THE GST OF O
CHSTMA PASRELL AROUND
YOIAVE NODEA H YOUAN
CHGE WHAT ALRDY HAPPENED.
WILLVEN EBDTH TTHE LIE
BU SOOGEEE REMPTN.
AMOT SEE S SE THAT'